Picking a good threshold
value is often challenging.
A Receiver Operator
Characteristic curve,
or ROC curve, can
help you decide
which value of the
threshold is best.
The ROC curve for
our problem is shown
on the right of this slide.
The sensitivity, or true
positive rate of the model,
is shown on the y-axis.
And the false positive rate,
or 1 minus the specificity,
is given on the x-axis.
The line shows how these
two outcome measures
vary with different
threshold values.
The ROC curve always
starts at the point (0, 0).
This corresponds to a
threshold value of 1.
If you have a
threshold of 1, you
will not catch any
poor care cases,
or have a sensitivity of 0.
But you will correctly
label of all the good care
cases, meaning you have a
false positive rate of 0.
The ROC curve always
ends at the point (1,1),
which corresponds to a
threshold value of 0.
If you have a
threshold of 0, you'll
catch all of the
poor care cases,
or have a sensitivity
of 1, but you'll
label all of the good care
cases as poor care cases
too, meaning you have a
false positive rate of 1.
The threshold decreases as
you move from (0,0) to (1,1).
At the point (0,
0.4), or about here,
you're correctly
labeling about 40%
of the poor care cases with a
very small false positive rate.
On the other hand, at
the point (0.6, 0.9),
you're correctly labeling about
90% of the poor care cases,
but have a false
positive rate of 60%.
In the middle,
around (0.3, 0.8),
you're correctly labeling about
80% of the poor care cases,
with a 30% false positive rate.
The ROC curve captures all
thresholds simultaneously.
The higher the threshold,
or closer to (0, 0),
the higher the specificity
and the lower the sensitivity.
The lower the threshold,
or closer to (1,1),
the higher the sensitivity
and lower the specificity.
So which threshold
value should you pick?
You should select
the best threshold
for the trade-off
you want to make.
If you're more concerned with
having a high specificity
or low false positive
rate, pick the threshold
that maximizes the
true positive rate
while keeping the false
positive rate really low.
A threshold around (0.1,
0.5) on this ROC curve
looks like a good
choice in this case.
On the other hand, if
you're more concerned
with having a high sensitivity
or high true positive rate,
pick a threshold that minimizes
the false positive rate
but has a very high
true positive rate.
A threshold around
(0.3, 0.8) looks
like a good choice in this case.
You can label the
threshold values in R
by color-coding the curve.
The legend is
shown on the right.
This shows us that-- say
we want to pick a threshold
value around here.
This corresponds to between the
aqua color and the green color.
Or it looks like about
a threshold of 0.3.
Instead, if we wanted to
pick a threshold around here,
this looks like the start
of the darker blue color,
and looks like it's probably
a threshold around 0.2.
We can also add specific
threshold labels
to the curve in
R. This helps you
see which threshold
value you want to use.
Let's go into R and see how
to generate these ROC curves.
To generate ROC curves in R, we
need to install a new package.
We'll use the same two
commands as we did earlier
in the lecture, but this
time the name of the package
is ROCR.
So first type
install.packages("ROCR"),
and hit Enter.
Since we picked a CRAN mirror
already in this R session,
we shouldn't have
to pick it again.
You know the package
is done installing
when you see the
arrow and blinking
cursor in your R console.
Now let's load the package
using the library function.
Recall that we made
predictions on our training set
and called them predictTrain.
We'll use these predictions
to create our ROC curve.
First, we'll call the
prediction function of ROCR.
We'll call the output of
this function ROCRpred,
and then use the
prediction function.
This function takes
two arguments.
The first is the
predictions we made
with our model, which
we called predictTrain.
The second argument is the true
outcomes of our data points,
which in our case, is
qualityTrain$PoorCare.
Now, we need to use the
performance function.
This defines what
we'd like to plot
on the x and y-axes
of our ROC curve.
We'll call the output
of this ROCRperf,
and use the performance
function, which
takes as arguments the output
of the prediction function,
and then what we want
on the x and y-axes.
In this case, it's
true positive rate,
or "tpr", and false
positive rate, or "fpr".
Now, we just need to plot
the output of the performance
function, ROCRperf.
You should see the ROC curve
pop up in a new window.
This should look exactly like
the one we saw on the slides.
Now, you can add colors by
adding one additional argument
to the plot function.
So in your R console, hit the
up arrow, and after ROCRperf,
type colorize=TRUE,
and hit Enter.
If you go back to
your plot window,
you should see the ROC
curve with the colors
for the threshold values added.
Now finally, let's add the
threshold labels to our plot.
Back in your R console, hit the
up arrow again to get the plot
function, and after
colorize=TRUE,
we'll add two more arguments.
The first is
print.cutoffs.at=seq(0,1,0.1),
which will print the threshold
values in increments of 0.1.
If you want finer increments,
just decrease the value of 0.1.
And then the final argument
is text.adj=c(-0.2,1.7),
and hit enter.
If you go back to
your plot window,
you should see the ROC curve
with threshold values added.
Using this curve, we can
determine which threshold value
we want to use depending
on our preferences
as a decision-maker.
In the next video,
we'll discuss how
to assess the
strength of our model.